JASON TITUS: Thank you, Paul.
So we have a couple minutes
while we get the chairs set up.
I did want to take a quick poll.
After seeing all of
this great information
about the things you can
do on the mobile web,
I wanted to see how many
people are actually going
to give to build out a
progressive mobile web app,
going forward, based
on what you just saw?
All right.
Very glad to hear it.
We're certainly very excited
about all the things that
are now possible and
the improvements that
have been made to start to
make the mobile web much closer
to what the app experience is.
Let's bring the
panel members out.
So I hope you guys
have been enjoying
the content this evening.
I know we had--
[APPLAUSE]
So I'm really happy
to bring together
a set of folks who have
experience both in building
apps and investing
in their ecosystem
here, as well as
building products
for consumers across India.
So very quickly, we have
Anand, who's the Chief Product
Officer from Snapdeal.
Nishant is here.
He's CEO and co-founder
of CultureAlley,
who makes Hello English.
We have Sudhir, who is the
Managing Director IDG Ventures.
And we have Jay Kota, who
is from Google and managing
the engineering in
the Hyderabod office.
So as a first
question, I was going
to ask an easy one
to get started.
So what is some
of the advice you
would give someone who's just
getting started in this market?
Like if they're early,
early stage, what
are the things from what
you've learned that you
think would be the most
useful bit of advice
to get them going?
Right here.
NISHANT PATNI: So
from my perspective--
I think Scott talked about
this earlier as well--
I think what's most
critical is to stay focused
on a particular pain point and
keep talking to the customer,
again and again, while
you're reiterating.
So in my sense, it's
just about designing it
correctly for this one,
target customer that you have.
It's understand his pain
point and talking to them
again and again.
And really, it's designing
it to solve that problem.
Oftentimes, as
engineers, we start out
from what we can do versus
what is it that's really needed
to solve that point point.
And I think that's where we
need to continue to be focused.
JASON TITUS: Sudhir, how about
for companies you invest in?
SUDHIR SETHI: Yeah.
I think what we've seen is
what succeeds at the seed
and early stage is
solve a problem.
I think that's a very
fundamental issue.
You're not building the
best technology, or the best
product, or the best
service-- you're
solving a real, real problem.
And that, obviously,
has corollaries
of better technology
and a better product.
I think the second issue
is execute, execute,
execute to perfection.
And I would just
leave it at that
because there's nothing like
capital efficient execution.
There's nothing like
timely execution.
There's nothing like execution.
And those firms which have done
this right from the beginning
develop a DNA which is
unsurpassable by anybody else.
JASON TITUS: Yeah.
Exactly.
JAY KOTA: So first of
all, if you're actually
working on start ups and
[INAUDIBLE], probably
congratulations.
This is the right
time, in India,
to actually try out your idea.
Certainly.
One of the things that we have
noticed over a period of time
is that India is a
very diverse market.
So start making
some early insights
and building early
insights around what
you're trying to solve.
And be ready to be proven wrong.
So a lot of times, you don't
actually get the market
or you may not get the market
exactly at the first time.
It needs lot of iteration.
So that's one thing.
Be open.
Be ready to be proven wrong.
Build feedback loops, whether
it's the user testing,
A/B testing, data analysis.
It's really important to
learn, and tune, and pivot
your strategy.
A few other things we
heard in the past sessions
around fit for India.
So these are important.
Most of the issues are
really, really relevant
to the end users.
I think those are
some of the things
that you really
have to worry about.
JASON TITUS: So actually,
one of the points
you raised is, I believe, really
relevant for a couple of you.
With the diversity of India--
I've only been here a few days,
but just seeing the wide range
of experiences, and language,
and sort of the
urban, rural split--
when you're building
out a product that's
supposed to go
across all of India,
how do you balance these things?
Anand, do you--
ANAND CHANDRASEKARAN:
I had a nice story
planned for the last question.
[LAUGHING]
JASON TITUS: Well, feel free.
ANAND CHANDRASEKARAN: This is
actually very fresh for us.
I think one of the
things that struck me
when I started building
products in India
was that it's
really like building
for 22 different countries.
And I think to try to
build for one persona can
be very frustrating.
And I would say,
more than anything,
just embrace the fact that
there is 22 different personas.
It means that if you
succeed with, let's say,
five, or six, or seven
of them, you probably
are going to have quite
a sizable user base.
And so it's actually
an opportunity.
And so I think there
are so many examples.
There is an entire
company that I
met when I was at Airtel,
which had built a $100 million
business and didn't have
a single smartphone user.
It was a start up called Vuclip,
whose entire user base was only
on 2G phones.
And actually, they
were wondering
how they were going to
go after smartphone users
because, at that time, they
didn't have a single smartphone
user.
And it actually blew
my mind that you
could build $100 million video
business in India with very
little smartphone user base.
And so I think it's actually
more of an opportunity
that you might think.
The other thing I
would say is, in a way,
tying it to the last question.
I think it's very important
to come in every so often
and take a fresh look
at your own business.
I think things are changing
incredibly fast in India.
And I think just because you
assume something three months
ago, it may not be valid today.
And so I would almost go
to the extent of saying,
assume that you got
fired, and new people came
into the business, and
they had no baggage,
and they were just looking
at everything a fresh.
What decisions would they
make about the business today?
And sometimes that cycle
might be even once every
three months because there are
just so many smartphone users.
The number one
smartphone vendor seems
to be evolving every three
months in India as well.
So I think it's actually more
of an opportunity than probably
any other part of the world.
JASON TITUS: Are there
things that, with you
trying to go after
non-English speakers,
you had to go through?
NISHANT PATNI: Absolutely.
And just to give you a
context, I'm actually that one.
I'm just sitting wrong.
But we are actually
behind this app
called the Hello English
app, which is actually
helping about 85
[INAUDIBLE] learners
speak basic, conversational
English every day.
So we are, currently, the number
one educational app in India.
But what that does is it
takes 15 different vernacular
language speakers and helps them
learn basic English that they
can use if they are a
driver, or if they are
a delivery boy, or something.
And it allows them to use it
offline, on their smart phones.
So now, the question that you
mentioned about how do you
deal with the diversity,
in terms of cultures.
It's very interesting for
us because we don't see this
as one behemoth, when we're
dealing with this customer
base.
We actually cut each of
these linguistic communities
differently.
And we actually design for
each of them independently.
Because what happens
is when somebody's
starting to think
in Tamil and he's
trying to converse
in English, it's
completely different
from somebody
who's starting out from
Hindi, or Urdu, or Bengali,
for that matter.
So we treat each of these
linguistic communities pretty
much independent.
And then all the
content that we design
for them are really keeping
these subtleties in mind.
That's one.
The other thing is that
reaching to such a large user
base in India required
us to really re-think
the tech behind the app.
And as the session before
really pointed out,
we've design the app
such that it works
offline in most scenarios.
So what we see is people
will download our app,
and take them to their
villages, and distribute them
to their near and dear ones.
And the way it's
been designed is
that it will continue
to work offline
perfectly well, for most cases.
Only if you have to
update your content,
do you need to come
online to do it.
And that sort of helped
us a lot in gaining
this sort of traction and
reaching out to the masses.
JASON TITUS: Yeah.
One of unique things about
this kind of user base,
where you have so many
people coming online
for the first time, is
that they don't necessarily
have an expectation for
how things should work.
And you really have
the opportunity--
you have both the challenge
and the opportunity of they
don't necessarily have the
experience that you can just
guide them how you've
got other users,
but you also have
somewhat of a clean slate.
You get to come up
with new things.
How do you guys deal
with both of those?
ANAND CHANDRASEKARAN: So
I'll take a crack at that.
Just speaking from
our perspective,
we started an e-commerce a
little over three years ago
and there have been
established players
who've had probably 10,000
people, $500 million
in funding.
And yet we're roughly neck
and neck in e-commerce today.
And we actually had an internal
conversation about that.
And we were saying, actually,
we should be really paranoid.
We really worried about
that because if someone
like us could start a
business in that same space
and just use really
good execution
to get neck and neck with
someone who's been around
for five more years,
then maybe there's
someone there today who
could do that tomorrow.
I think, from the perspective
of the question you're asking,
there are so many people coming
online with just no baggage
and the smartphone
is pretty much
the only device they've seen.
And so the fact that you might
have had a great PC experience
means nothing to them.
They're just consuming
from their phone.
The fact that you
had a great iOS app
might mean nothing to them.
And so I think that context
is extremely important.
And as previous speakers
were saying, a lot of them
could only consume
you from mobile web.
And they might not even
know that you have an app
or that you have a
desktop experience.
So I think it's
extremely important
to have a great experience
across all form factors
because you never know what that
journey is going to look like.
And also, one of
the things that's
been shocking for me is that you
might think that someone coming
online for the first time might
have very modest aspirations
for what they want to do online.
In fact, the opposite is true.
They want everything.
And they want everything
with the same intensity
that any of us would want it.
And so the adoption
that we see-- sometimes
you think, maybe they
need a crash course
in how to do e-commerce.
And actually, they don't.
They understand what
cash on delivery is.
delivery promises.
So very complex,
e-commerce concepts
that we try to
explain internally
are very obvious
to people coming
online for the first time.
So actually, the learning
curve is incredibly fast.
And so, in a very timely
sense, we launched our service
in 12 languages yesterday.
And we feel like
the people who will
consume it are not the
same people who consumed us
in English.
And so to Nishant's
point, I think
the context is very different
for someone who's only
going to use us in Gujarati.
They don't care that we have
a great English experience.
So I think that's a bit
of scary thing, actually.
The fact that someone
could start today,
and have a great
language experience,
and could become
as big as someone
who's been around for eight
years, or nine years, or 10
years.
JASON TITUS: So you're
starting over, again and again,
in each of these
different languages.
SUDHIR SETHI: I'll
just add to that.
I think the onboarding
experience of a new consumer--
technology baseline
today is such,
whether it's a four year old
child or an 80 year old adult,
that I haven't seen much
of a time difference
except for just
because of the age.
And I'll give you an
example, which is last week,
we had to go to Ajanta and
Ellora to see the caves.
And my driver had actually
never used Google Maps earlier.
So I just told him, how come
you're not using Google Maps?
He took two trips, within
the city of Bangalore,
from maybe eight
to 10 kilometers,
to onboard himself
onto Google Maps.
He downloaded it
himself, by the way,
because he knows how to
download [INAUDIBLE].
And to that extent, for
him, Google Map download
was no difference.
And we drove down from
Bangalor to Aurangabad
using Google Maps.
So the onboarding process,
because of baseline technology,
is very simple.
So I don't think that's a
big issue in today's market.
Whether it is product discovery,
e-commerce, service discovery,
I don't think it's a big issue.
JAY KOTA: I'm not
sure if my mic--
I would like to borrow
one of the quotes
from Nandan Nilekani.
He keeps talking
about, how do you
take advantage of no legacy,
when it comes to India?
I really feel like
starting from a clean state
really empowers
in some use cases.
There's a chance to
leapfrog, like what
you see happening probably
in the payments right now.
Like India maybe leapfrogs
and create [INAUDIBLE]
all together.
Maybe India goes
directly into phone
as a Wallet mobile payments.
So there's some
interesting experiences
that you can think of without
worrying about legacy.
So that's one point to
really take advantage of.
From a user experience
point of view,
I see a lot of Indian apps
trying different gamifications.
Normally, it's
kind of violating,
let's say, established standards
of apps in the Western world,
but it's very
successful in India.
So it kind of gives us
a chance to challenge,
and start fresh, and start
from first principles,
and do things right.
JASON TITUS: So what
kinds of technology
do you feel are really missing?
One of things that seemed clear
from what others are saying
is with all of these different
scripts and things like that,
it sounds like a lot of
folks are having to come up
with their own solutions.
What do you see as the
pieces that are missing
and that hold folks back for
making great experiences?
NISHANT PATNI: Yeah.
So I think, in our
case, one of the things
that poses challenges
is just the access bit.
So one is, obviously, the
availability of infrastructure.
And secondly, it's
just how affordability
is that infrastructure
to these users.
And we really need to keep
these constraints in mind
when you have to
design a product which
can scale massively.
So in our case,
what's interesting
is that every fourth user who
downloads our app, actually
downloads it from a
non-Play store source, which
means that he's getting it
from a Bluetooth channel,
from somebody who's
sitting next to him
in his office, or a
friend, et cetera.
But he's not wanting to
spend that 10 MB or 11 MB,
downloading it from
the Play store.
So these are sort
of nuances that you
need to sort of understand
when you're getting
into the shoes of the customer.
And really, when you have
to design an experience,
you have to design it
under these limitations,
so that it can benefit the
largest number of people.
So in our case, it's this
access and the infrastructure,
which we keep in mind.
And obviously, if this
was taken care of,
we would have designed
a completely different
experience.
It would be really a complete
voice recognition and image
recognition sort of experience.
But now, given
these constraints,
we have to design for
whatever can sell the most.
SUDHIR SETHI: This is
an interesting question.
300 odd million internet users.
Sometime in the future,
it's hopefully one billion.
How do these one billion
people onboard themselves
for product discovery
and service discovery?
I think our viewpoint is that
interim solutions-- and this is
the investor
viewpoint-- are possibly
going to be keyboard
oriented, whether it
is a English to Hindi
transliteration or a keyboard.
I think the natural
phenomena of voice
enabled transactions
is going to take over.
And that's the only way, to my
mind, a large volume of people
will enable onboarding.
To give an example, if
somebody in Tamil Nadu
wants to book a ticket,
they can go to Yatra
and try to key in all the stuff.
If he doesn't know English and
if Tamil is not so efficient,
he actually can't
book that ticket.
But if you just
says, in Tamil, I
want to book a ticket
from Delhi, to Chennai,
to Bangalore, then
is that transaction
possible to be completed?
So I think I agree
with what you said,
in terms of India skipping.
India is a country
which skips many things.
It skipped the phone.
It skipped many other things.
It's going to skip
the credit card.
I think India's going to
skip the whole keyboard
orientation of
onboarding of a consumer
and literally look at
voice down the line.
Let's see what happens.
JASON TITUS: Interesting.
JAY KOTA: I'm
probably going to be
echoing some of the
feedback I've been
getting from the developers.
One of the first things to
really proliferate in view
of India based other
apps is I keep hearing
about mostly input
and output methods.
Vernacular speech
recognition is a technology
I would totally want.
Maybe handwriting
recognition as well.
I feel like, if we can actually
support technology pieces that
helps apps deal with
slow connections
and shaky connections in
the network libraries, that
could be a really
interesting infrastructure
to be used within the apps.
In a way, [INAUDIBLE] offline
is a great tool to maybe use
and maybe we should
do more of that.
That's pretty much it.
ANAND CHANDRASEKARAN:
I think, just
building on the
conversation so far,
I would say there's probably a
ton of opportunity on the user
experience itself.
It's just such a
fundamental part
of what people are consuming.
Whether you take into
account what kind
of network connectivity
the person is on,
what kind of past experience
the person has had,
what the device
is capable of, you
know what people
like this person
have done in the past--
there's so much context
around a mobile experience.
And I feel like, even today,
mobile experience is really
built as if they're desktop
experiences with only the IP
address available.
You know what the
weather is like outside.
You know where they user is.
And you know if it's raining
around the user or not.
You can probably detect if
the user's listening to music
while they're shopping or not.
So I think all that
context has really not
been taken into account
and into the experience.
And my sense is also what shows
up in the experience could
evolve a lot, based on context.
And I feel like today,
at best, we probably
remember the last
item that was not
purchased in the shopping cart.
And I think it feels,
to me, like it's still,
for lack of a better
way of saying it,
what worked for American
e-commerce has been imported
into India.
Over the next few years,
I think e-commerce
will be built for the next 100
million people who come online.
And as a result of it, there
will be an incredible amount
of disruption that happens both
for existing types of companies
that get built as well as
existing modes of consumption,
et cetera.
And I think a lot of
what we've discussed here
will sort of go in
as input material.
Like for instance, if you take
slow connections as an example,
one could say, look,
that's a temporary problem.
It's going to go away.
The fact is that
no telco in India
has more than five megahertz
of contiguous spectrum anywhere
in India.
So it literally is
the laws of physics.
They're never going to
have more than that amount
of bandwidth reliably available.
And so slow connections
are a reality in India.
But if I'm connected to
Wi-Fi at home, backed by a 4G
connection, the fact that I'm
otherwise on a slow connection
doesn't matter now.
And so the experiences
have to be very different
when I'm on those two
different contexts.
So I think that will
evolve considerably.
JASON TITUS: So do
you all feel that some
of these solutions
that might be really
evolved here, in India, as
sort of unique experiences,
that you might actually be able
to be successful in bringing
them outside of India and
to other parts of the world?
And if so, what do you think
those opportunities are?
Do you want to start?
NISHANT PATNI: Yeah.
SUDHIR SETHI: Sorry.
Go ahead.
NISHANT PATNI: No.
SUDHIR SETHI: So absolutely.
I think, based on some of the
companies which we have seen,
India has given tremendous scale
in a very short period of time.
And I'll give you maybe
one or two examples.
We have communicologists
in information security.
And within the first three or
four years of their existence,
they enabled
information security
for the [INAUDIBLE] program.
So in the fourth year
of their existence,
they had 350 million people
in India where information
security was enabled.
Now for a company to
achieve 350 million people
was unheard of
anywhere in the world.
That enabled them to go
into North America, the UK
and get large clients because
the platform capability
on scale was not questioned.
So that's another example.
We have another
company called NewGen
in traditional transformation.
One of their first
customers was LIC in India.
Then LIC has over 100
million insurance consumers.
So their additional
transformational platform
worked with 100
million consumers.
For them to go
outside, there were not
questioned on the
scalability of technology.
So that's an example of how
not just the technology being
innovative, but the scale
of global corporations
or consumers from India works.
NISHANT PATNI: Actually,
to your point, Sudhir,
even in our case, what
we did was we actually
just looked at India
and tried to design
a product for the
typical Indian consumer.
But then, what we realized
was that very similar market
conditions exist as we look
outside of India as well.
So what we did was we tried
using the same technology
and adapted the content
for Pakistan, for example.
And it worked.
We did the same thing
for Bangladesh, Nepal,
and the Middle East.
And I'm proud to say that in
seven off all these markets,
we are the number
one educational app.
And because what we
did was we really
learned from what
India was telling us.
We really learned
what technology
was finding most used.
What use cases, what content
was finding most relevant.
And then we adapted
them to these markets
to sort of fit their needs.
And yes, in that
context, India did
help us leapfrog a lot of the
local incumbents who were there
in those markets.
JASON TITUS: We'll ask
one last question, which
is, just looking at all of the
opportunities for technology
to help people in a
country like India,
how do you think of social
entrepreneurship for good?
What do you think of the
opportunities for technology
and technology companies to make
Indian people's lives better?
ANAND CHANDRASEKARAN: I think
probably the two biggest
opportunities are
education and health
care that could use the most
disruption through technology.
And it'll actually be
in very unlikely ways.
So I'll give you a
very simple example.
In a lot of tier-2
and tier-3 cities,
one of the most popular
products that sell on Snapdeal
is actually glucose monitors and
just blood testing equipment.
And today, the way
it happens is someone
takes a bunch of suit cases
and goes over to a big city
because they have to go to a
proper medical health equipment
store.
And they buy this testing
equipment because most of them
don't work well, or they're
not accurate, et cetera.
And literally, it has the
ability to save lives.
And the fact that it could be
delivered in 5,000 in a day
or over two-- I think it's
a very small example of how
technology, plus access,
plus a level playing
field kind of really changes
the game for what's possible,
from a health care perspective.
I think the same for education.
I think we have a great
example right here.
I think a lot of
people sometimes
don't go to school because
the walk every day to school
is just so far.
And the opportunity for
access plus technology
to bring education
to where they are,
and allow them get
educated at their own pace,
and their own appetite--
I think are probably
two of the most interesting.
SUDHIR SETHI: I would
mention one area, which
is, to me, a bridge
between social--
and I'll bracket that
with financial inclusion--
and pure commerce.
India-- the legal
India, if I may add--
is a cashless society.
If you look at e-commerce,
about half of e-commerce
is cash on delivery
today, in the country.
It may be a little bit lower,
depending on the company.
But we are talking about
something like 7 to 8 billion
in a year.
About 45% of railway
tickets in the country
are bought by cash, which
is about $40 billion.
About 80&% off petrol and diesel
consumer is bought by cash.
I don't have the number
in my head for that.
And about 80% of LPG by
consumers are bought by cash.
If I just add up
these numbers, they
add up to you a humungous--
close to the $80 odd billion
today.
And if you add up the SME
sector and the kirana shops,
India is transacting commerce,
even by the government,
in cash.
Now which also means that
many of these consumers
and businesses are not in
the financial inclusion
definition in some sense.
I think there's a
huge opportunity
for cash-full transaction
in electronic form
to happen amongst all these.
And there is a very
strong social element,
but there's an extremely
strong commerce element here.
That, to me, is going
to be a game changer
as far as technology
is concerned,
as far as India's concern
in the next 10 to 15 years.
JASON TITUS: All right.
Well, we've actually
used up all of our time.
And I entirely
appreciate that we are
sitting between you and dinner.
So I want to thank
all of our panelists
for their great insights.
[APPLAUSE]
And generally, I hope
you all appreciated
all of the presentations today.
We're really glad that
you could come out.
We, at Google, are very
committed to making
developers successful.
And if you ever
feel that there are
things that we could be doing
better, please, reach out.
We love to hear feedback.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]